if you want to know the chances of
nuclear war over the island of Taiwan
you need to know what's going on in the
mind of one man
China's president Xi Jinping
we need to have a better understanding
what are his instincts uh what does he
want his legacy to be
the trouble is it's surprisingly
difficult to know
presidency doesn't give wide-ranging
interviews or use social media
and what we do know about him is tightly
controlled by the Communist Party his
life story is hidden behind a brutal
propaganda and censorship machine
so what really happened in presidency's
past to make him the man he is today he
saw Terrible Things his own family
suffered terrible things and what might
this tell us about his Ambitions for
China and its place in the world
this is the image Xi Jinping wants you
to see
the Helmsman to use a title State media
sometimes give him guiding the nation
forward
he has an extremely sophisticated
well-crafted image in the state media
and that is the only media that people
in China can see they're very good at
showing him as this kind of a cross
between a man of the people and a kind
of benevolent model
alongside the military parades he's also
often seen swapping anecdotes with the
party faithful foreign
curated image as in every man couldn't
be further from the truth
presidency was born into Communist Party
royalty his father was a revolutionary
Pioneer and high-ranking party member
and C was part of the generation known
as the princelings he grew up in immense
privilege he went to a top boarding
school with orchards and a swimming pool
and a really high quality food at a time
when you know hundreds of millions of
Chinese were living in abject poverty
foreign
[Music]
school and this is our
classrooms linan Yang was one of C's
contemporaries a fellow child of the
elite
her father knew C's dad and like him she
grew up in an elite school why was in
the elementary school that was a
boarding school most of my classmates
parents came from the same Ministry from
my father's Ministry so we played really
well together but this gilded childhood
didn't last
when Xi Jinping and Lee Nan Yang were
both just nine years old their fathers
were purged in the political struggles
caused by Mao Zedong
because he didn't trust his own Elites
at certain key moments Chairman Mao
decided to basically blow up his own
system he felt that protected him from
his own enemies inside China's ruling
establishment he had you know heavy
Weaponry being used in some cities he
had instances of cannibalism where
people at their own enemies in a kind of
bloodlust
both nanyang and C's fathers were jailed
during the purges and nanyang can
sympathize with what sea must have gone
through
my father's position was lower than
xinji's father so I could imagine the
job from the top level to the lower
level must be even more tremendous
towards gdps I mean
all of a sudden the people become very
strange and they kept a distance from
you and even some adults show their
hatred toward you you couldn't
understand as a nine years old child
[Music]
must have had found impact on young sea
and helped to shape his view of power
he's given some extraordinary kind of
interviews before he became the top
leader where he's talked about you know
some people see the kind of the the
parades and the flowers when they think
of power but he can still remember that
what he calls the bullpens these kind of
makeshift prisons where people who are
purged in the maoriers were placed the
extreme brutality of his own youth
taught him the lesson that China can
look stable but that chaos is always a
possibility if you don't have absolute
discipline and if you don't focus on
National Security
if you want to know more about how XI
Japanese childhood shaped his vision for
China you should check out the prince
it's the economist's first ever
long-form podcast series and I'm really
excited to be hosting it to listen click
on the link
while C has openly spoken about the
horror of his childhood and the lessons
it taught him he presents a much Rosier
view of his teenage years
aged 15 he was sent down to the
countryside to do hard manual labor as
part of mazedong's cultural revolution
many special trains depart carrying
students to the countryside
[Music]
the idea was that Urban Youth should
learn from the peasantry to strengthen
their revolutionary spirit
for millions of Chinese of his
generation that was a disaster that was
where they missed out on their entire
education many of them never recovered
the chance to have a good schooling or a
good University education many of them
feel that those were completely lost
years
[Music]
but for presidency being sent to the
countryside was he says a character
building experience
one that would make him the leader he is
today
and it is this experience working the
land and living in a humble cave that he
draws on when he presents himself as a
man of the people
[Music]
foreign
but it wasn't quite that simple
at first he hated hard labor and
actually ran away he says he didn't know
how to work in the countryside in the
ways that were required of him and he
took up smoking because that was like an
acceptable way for him to take a break
after just three months he flees and
goes back to the city where he then is
sentenced to a hard labor gang and has
to lay sewer pipes
you might expect that these experiences
in his youth would have led him to hate
the Communist Party
but it seems to have had the opposite
effect
nanyang says it's easy to see why
My Generation the only job was to be a
revolutionary otherwise you become the
counter revolutionary there is no
another way cgp didn't lose his devotion
and in fact decided that the party was
the only game in town and perhaps a
lesson in Xi Jinping went from now and
from his own childhood was that no one
is safe unless you are at the very top
of the Communist Party
foreign
was to climb the party ladder as a local
official
we don't have that much information
about what Xi Jinping was doing in the
provinces but Xi Jinping took an
approach of hiding and biting so he
wanted to keep a very low profile while
he was Rising through the ranks of the
Communist Party
in rarely seen footage from the time he
seems a devoted family man and he is
nearly overshadowed by his baby daughter
Ming Zoo
when this clip was filmed he was working
as a local official in fujen Province
the official story of his time there is
that the economy grew and pollution
decreased but actually the biggest
corruption scandal in Chinese history
was unfolding
the man at the center of it was Lai
Chang Singh he ran a multi-billion
dollar smuggling ring for goods
including cars and oil through the port
in fujan Province where Xi Jinping was a
senior party official and later Governor
what's really interesting is that
hundreds of government officials had
their careers ended because of this
Scandal but not Xi Jinping Xi Jinping
not only escaped unscathed he was
actually promoted to an even better job
within the Communist party was C aware
of the smuggling ring
some of his closest colleagues were
implicated but there's no evidence he
was involved
[Music]
he would continue his quiet Ascent until
the party Congress in 2007 when it
became clear that his time in the
provinces had paid off
and C was in line for the top job
first time that the outside world knew
for sure that Xi Jinping was going to be
the top leader of the Communist party
was when people looked at the order that
they walked on stage and they saw that
Xi Jinping was in front of a man called
Lika Chang who was the other possible
top guy and that level of secrecy is
like something from a history book it's
like something from you know Stalin's
Soviet Union and that is still how China
runs itself in 2022
foreign
[Music]
so what would Xi Jinping want for China
after surviving the chaos of the
cultural revolution security and
stability were front and center
there is a new focus a really dramatic
focus on National Security there needs
to be constant vigilance discipline
order security suspicion of Outsiders to
achieve this C wasted no time in
eliminating the opposition
via a wholesale Crackdown on corruption
which was even dramatized in this hit TV
show
one of the remarkable things is that 10
years into his rule we really do not see
overt challenges to him well there's one
faction the Xi Jinping faction and
that's in charge
he has maintained control by
dramatically increasing the level of
surveillance
over half of the world's CCTV cameras
are now in China
and he has kept track of his Citizens
online
Eric Lou has seen this from the inside
he used to work 11 hours a day censoring
content on weiwa the Chinese equivalent
of Twitter
um
Rick says after sieging took over
censorship around the leader's image
dramatically increased
um
[Music]
and years ago
dancers worked alongside Eric at weibo
now he says tech companies have tens of
thousands
editing online content in almost real
time
[Music]
it's essentially a bet that previous
attempts at a kind of absolute police
state that they failed not because it's
impossible but because you couldn't do
it with kind of filing cabinets and guys
listing on the phone but if you have ai
if you have enough computing power that
you can make it work for the first time
in human history you have a police state
that believes it has the technology to
have total knowledge of what an entire
population is doing
sees tight grip of the population may
now continue for decades in 2018 two
term limits for the President and Vice
President were scrapped so that speed
can effectively rule for life
the argument is you need one man who has
the trust of the entire Chinese people
the Helmsman steering the ship of China
through this sort of epocal storm so
given his focus on National Security
what might this mean for the rest of the
world
C has proved capable of fearsome shows
of strength as in Hong Kong
and a willingness to embrace more
aggressive rhetoric
under Xi Jinping
China's tone has become a lot sharper
Chinese diplomats going out on
television in the outside world and
saying surprisingly aggressive things
that kind of directive that comes from
Xi Jinping
the question of the moment is what might
this mean for the island of Taiwan
could see feel that he has unfinished
business there if Xi Jinping could
successfully invade and take Taiwan then
he would be the final Victor of the
Chinese Civil War that ended in 1949 he
would be greater than Mao Zedong who won
but didn't finish it and so that would
make him an immortal in Chinese history
or has he invested too much in making
China strong and prosperous to risk it
all on a war that could provoke another
nuclear superpower
no matter his decision
the actions of Xi Jinping will continue
to shape China and all our lives for
years to come
I'm still in Wong I'm the host of the
economists first ever long-form podcast
series it's about Xi Jinping and it's
called the prince to listen click on the
link thank you very much for watching
and don't forget to subscribe